it's it's the same argument people use
for eugenics do you know what Eugenics
is so eugenics basically when you're
when you're getting a more pure
population and so a lot of times people
would bring things like low IQ people
need to be exterminated like poor people
need to be exterminated and when you're
using the argument of if they have a bad
life that's how eugenesis used to make
their point because you're basically
you're implying that like four people
have less of a right to life than rich
people no we're not we're not implying
that I think let's do this if that baby
is born when it could have been
abolished that could lead into a worser
life when it could have when that could
have been prevented
right so you don't think that's saying
that poor people should have a less of a
right to life than rich people it's not
about poor or Rich like it's about
quality of life that has nothing to do
you could be poor and still have a good
quality of life like that has nothing to
do with it